So in our original version of the grammar, only 4 strings were derivable.
Here's our grammar from before.
I'm going to add just 1 rule, and that one itty bitty rule
is going to give me phenomenal cosmic power.
Here I've added a rule to allow us to make compound subjects.
This rule is super special awesome.
Let me show you a new derivation that uses this new rule.
Starting from sentence, we go to subject verb,
subject and subject verb, students and subject verb,
students and subject think, students and teachers think.
Here, right here when we turned this subject into subject and subject,
that's when we were using this starred rule.
And notice that now, rather than a 2-word sentence,
we've produced a 4-word sentence.
Amazing. Do students and teachers think?
That beggars belief.
Both of us think? Teachers certainly don't think.
Let's see how this plays out.
This new power that we've discussed
is called recursion in grammar.
You're already familiar with recursion in programming
where a function calls itself.
Here we can replace a non-terminal subject
with that same non-terminal and some other stuff,
so just as we might define factorial in terms of factorial of x - 1,
we can define subject in terms of subject and subject.
This is a recursive rewrite rule, and thus the whole thing
is now recursive grammar.
Recursive grammars, that's where all the real power is
because in essence, it allows a bit of a loop,
and this gives us some room for creativity.
This is how we can have a finite structure
that admits infinite utterances but not all utterances.